seit einigen jahren steht eine app im
transportbereich weltweit an der nummer
eins in fast jeder großstadt ist es
möglich über das handy persönliche
fahrer zu bestellen die einen dann genau
dorthin fahren wo man hin möchte in
einigen wenigen städten gibt es das
allerdings auch mit einem etwas anderen
transport mit viel spaß ich habe ein
wenig co2 umgestellt
ok wenn es über copter aber fast nur in
new york gibt dann müssen wir nach new
york um das zu testen und genau das
machen wir aber
warum das ganze eigentlich in new york
warum gibt's das nicht überall wieso
kann ich hier keinen helikopter aus der
kölner innenstadt an den flughafen
bestellt jeder der schon mal in new york
war weiß genau warum der verkehr ist
eine absolute tour je näher man an die
stadt heran werden desto weniger bewegt
man sich wirklich und das ist eigentlich
mehr ein stop and go es wird gehupt dann
kann ich nach vorne nach hinten nach
links nach rechts man steht einfach nur
man könnte jetzt meinen dafür gibt es
schon eine sehr einfache lösung die sich
über nennt die in new york auf super gut
ausgebaut ist aber das wäre natürlich
nicht extrem genug für new york deswegen
geht man eine ebene höher und fliegt mit
dem helikopter abseits davon dass ich
mein leben lang schon mal helikopter
fliegen wollte möchte ich auch
herausfinden wie viel zeit erspart das
wirklich und vor allem wie viel kostet
der ganze spaß im vergleich zu einer
normalen oberfeld nachdem ich gerade
eine stunde an der passkontrolle
verbracht habe bin ich endlich auf
freiem fuße in new york und von hier
müsste ich jetzt eigentlich einen
überkopf bestellen können denn natürlich
kann der nicht überall lampen ich kann
ihnen jetzt nicht einfach irgendwo in
new york bestellende landet auch wegen
dem dach und ich steig ein so ist es
nicht schön wär's es gibt natürlich
festen und eine dieser festen routen
startet genau hin und endet in downtown
manhattan deswegen müsste ich jetzt
eigentlich die ubs öffnen können und der
müsste mir das als option einfach direkt
neben den anderen optionen anzeigen also
über eco über black die ganzen
verschiedenen fahrzeuge und ein
helikopter ich warte schon sehr lange
auf diesen moment ist ein bisschen
aufgeregt über xxl black komfort green
pauli black suv
kein helikopter
ich sehe keinen helikopter desto mehr
und desto länger ich gesucht habe desto
mehr hat sich das gefühl in mir breit
gemacht das ist das einfach nicht mehr
gibt die suche ist vergeblich es gibt
keinen oberkopf da ich habe keine ahnung
woran es liegt ich hab gerade noch mal
gegoogelt und ich habe in den letzten
zwei jahren auch keine richtigen
berichte mehr darüber gefunden also es
gibt auch keine erfahrungsberichte auf
youtube und so ziemliche scheiße alles
was ich noch gefunden habt waren
irgendwelche pressemitteilung aus dem
release ja oder dem release monat wo
ganz krass berichtet wurde dass das
jetzt die neue transportmöglichkeit in
new york sein soll aber es gab einfach
keinen zu bestellen und dann an meinem
los auf der los und wo ich dachte es
gäbe schon keine möglichkeit mehr von
jay kay mit dem helikopter nach new york
zu kommen hat sich einen bericht wie
phönix aus der asche auf meinem handy
geöffnet dieser bericht gab an das ist
eine firma gibt die genau das macht was
über copter immer sein wollte und
scheinbar nie geschafft hat diese firma
heißt blade und bietet
flughafentransfers mit helikoptern
zwischen diesen beiden punkten und nicht
nur zwischen diesen beiden punkten
sondern auch zwischen downtown und den
hamptons also einem sehr teuren
wohngebiet in der nähe von new york wo
die ganzen banker und sowohl zwischen
new york und anderen städten in der nähe
zwischen wirklich unfassbar vielen
punkten und sogar ein abo system bei dem
man quasi eine helikopter flatrate
buchen kann also ziemlich krass und
genau die firma die ich gesucht habe
scheinbar ist alles gut blade scheint
genau das zu sein was über copter immer
sein wollte und wenn ich das hier
richtig sehe kann ich jetzt einfach
hierhin dem helikopter bestellt klar
eigentlich wäre mir lieber gewesen wenn
es wirklich immer gewesen wäre weil die
convenience das in einer app zu haben
und die möglichkeit zu haben einfach auf
schnell schnell das buchen zu können war
genau mein traum ich musste dann auf der
blade seite aber feststellen dass es im
prinzip wirklich genau das ist weil die
buchungen weil dieser ganze ablauf
unheimlich einfach war
10 funktioniert jetzt muss ich hier
daten von mir angeben wer ich bin und so
weiter
es scheint zu funktionieren
das ist der bericht
wie mac apps an der forderte nach der
buchung habe ich dann erfahren dass es
keine möglichkeit gibt direkt an jay kay
mit einem helikopter zu starten das gab
es damals bei über copter nicht und das
gibt es jetzt bei blade immer noch nicht
also ist landen keine helikopter an gfk
aber fünf minuten entfernt davon
um genau dorthin zu kommen gibt es
natürlich einen fahrservice den mann in
dem ticket direkt mit inbegriffen hat
und man wird nicht irgendwie abgeholt
sondern mit einem fucking es gelegt das
größte fetteste amerikanische auto
überhaupt hat mich dann an gft abgeholt
und zum hit
die ja das ist amerikanischer geht's
nicht
ja
in dem es gelingt war ich übrigens nicht
alleine sondern wir haben an allen
terminals alle leute eingesammelt die in
unserem gemeinsamen helikopter saß
darunter war ich ein 50-jähriger
business mann aus london und ein
wirklich sagen 25 jährige amerikaner der
seinen hund dabei hatte und absolut
unbeeindruckt von dem ganzen war er hat
mir auch erzählt dass er mittlerweile
zum sechsten oder siebten mal fliegt
weil er einfach keine lust auf den
verkehr es wird also tatsächlich
wirklich von amerikanern einfach als
dran sind genutzt abseits vom autofahren
es ist einfach eine möglichkeit von
jockey nach downtown zu kommen dieser
effekt hat uns jetzt zum heliport
gebracht jetzt geht's rein und dann mit
dem heli richtung downtown ich bin
richtig kommt am heliport angekommen ist
mir klar geworden dass es alles zu krass
durch getaktet ist wir hatten quasi
keine möglichkeit uns das alles mal so
ein bisschen anzuschauen sondern es ging
wirklich nur um den transport aus dem
auto raus sofort richtung helipad wir
mussten nicht noch extra einchecken das
war alles schon im auto vorher
kontrolliert worden alle vecsey nation
passes und so weiter also wir konnten
quasi einfach durchgehen und direkt auf
sie
mein allererster helikopter flug wird so
kommt
[Musik]
so unbeeindruckt schien der 25 jährige
dann doch nicht zu sein und hat sein
handy vor den new yorker skyline noch
mal gezeigt es war ein unglaubliches
gefühl gerade weil ich zehn stunden
vorher noch in frankfurt gestartet bin
und das einfach völlig unglaublich
oh mein gott
warte mal genau während ihr gerade
dieses video schaut wenn es rauskommt
ist dave also ich in der innenstadt und
versteckt geschenke überall in der stadt
wenn ihr also frühzeitig auf dieses
video geklickt habt habt ihr die
möglichkeit fette preise überall in der
kölner stattzufinden eines dieser
geschenke liegt genau hier und ich will
nicht zu viel verraten aber es ist von
apple und das kostet fast 1000 euro das
ist aber nicht das einzige sondern ich
war steckt noch eine menge mehr
geschenke folgt mir also auf insta dort
werdet ihr weitere informationen
bekommen und vergesst nicht diesen kanal
auf youtube zu abonnieren damit ihr das
in den folgenden wochen nicht verpasst
weil wir das noch weiter auf die spitze
treiben und das ganze nicht nur in köln
sondern deutschlandweit ich bin also
nicht nur innerhalb von ein paar stunden
über den atlantik in eine völlig andere
zeitzone geflogen sondern dann auch noch
mit dem helikopter nach downtown
manhattan was wirklich einfach
unglaublich im landeanflug ist mir dann
auch noch aufgefallen dass wir genau an
dem heliport landen an dem jordan
belfort tempelhof auf wallstreet vom fbi
festgenommen wird und vor dem so ein
bisschen weg wenn es ist wirklich
unglaublich gibt
wir sind wirklich nur fünf minuten
geflogen spot on 5 minuten und haben uns
eine stunde oder wahrscheinlich sogar
zwei stunden trafic gespaart weil
momentan thanksgiving ist völlig
verrückt das gefühl vom helikopter
fliegen war ziemlich genau so wie es mir
vorgestellt habe wir waren unheimlich
schnell unterwegs ist wurde keine zeit
verschwendet mit dem losfliegen der
motor war ja auch schon am laufen und
ich habe dann auch gemerkt dass der
helikopter kvasiny ausgemacht wird also
selbst wenn er landet wird er nicht
ausgemacht und es wird auch neue
passagiere gewartet sondern er läuft die
ganze zeit also läuft startet landet
lernt neue leute ein und es geht wieder
weiter die ganze zeit den ganzen tag die
erfahrung war es wirklich absolut wert
aber was war die erfahrung wird
insgesamt hat mich der flug 195 dollar
inklusive escalade abholung gekostet was
95 dollar teurer war als der angegebene
preis mit dem auto und das muss ich
sagen finde ich tatsächlich ziemlich
fährt mit dem auto hätte ich weil banks
giving sonntag war an dem super viele
amerikaner in new york angekommen sind
über zwei stunden der helikopter flug an
sich waren zwar nur fünf minuten aber
mit dem escalade zum heliport zu kommen
und so weiter hat sich insgesamt auf
einer zeit von 49 minuten addiert das
bedeutet an einem normalen ankunftstag
ist man vielleicht zehn 15 minuten
schneller das lohnt sich jetzt nicht
unbedingt außer man möchte die
erfahrungen an diesen genauen tag an dem
ich aber geflogen bin war es ein
absoluter traum ich habe 95 dollar mehr
bezahlt dafür aber eine stunde und zehn
minuten verkehr gespart eine super geile
erfahrung gehabt und bin am heliport
gelandet an dem jordan belfort
festgenommen worden es war wirklich
super super geil und ich kann es jedem
von euch nur empfehlen das zu machen
wenn ihr in new york an gfb ankommt und
dort ist es war wirklich richtig nach
das war nicht das einzige mal dass ich
in new york helikopter geflogen bin wenn
ihr das zweite und deutlich verrücktere
mal nicht verpassen wollt dann vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren das wir
gerne weiter und dann sehen wir uns am
sonntag zu einer neuen folge rolex
trader wieder cous cous cous macht's gut
schönes wochenende
[Musik]